quand j'ai une paralysie du sommeil je
pense juste que je vais mourir en fait
[Musique]
j'ai conscience que je suis là que je
suis réveillé mais mon corps lui est
complètement endormi c'est comme si je
sentais plus mon corps j'ai mes muscles
sont peut-être tendue je sais pas trop
en tout cas j'ai même un poids qui
s'appuie vraiment sur moi
ils ont deux distinctions en fait entre
mon corps et ma conscience et mes
muscles n'existe plus
[Musique]
ce
en fait paralysé lorsqu'on est en
sommeil de rêve un sommeil paradoxal et
il arrive qu'ils aient un petit
dysfonctionnement qui fait qu'on se
réveille du sommeil paradoxal et qu'on
reste paralysé alors que notre cerveau
est éveillé
[Musique]
j'ai vu apparaître dans l'entrée de la
porte
une silhouette blanchâtre un peu
fantomatique qui avait l'apparence d'une
vue une vieille dame et ça c'est cette
silhouette en fait elle s'est jetée sur
man a couru vers moi et j'ai essayé de
me débattre de crier sauf que en fait
mon corps ne voulait pas bouger et au
bout d'un moment au moment où j'ai
réussi par contre à me réveiller et j'y
retrouve la pièce comme a été quand je
me suis endormi et je ressemble presque
un soulagement
le soulagement de me réveiller et que
cela arrive il a duré très longtemps et
quand je me réjouirais vraiment à me
réveiller j'avoue que j'ai une angoisse
qui s'en va parce que je suis enfin
réveillé et souvent j'ai peur de me
rendormir jeu s'apprête parce que ça
recommence
[Musique]